you uh brought with you an awesome
puzzle for the viewers today Ivanka and
it's time to reveal the answer yeah I
have to say to everyone I mean what an
amazing try everyone actually got into
it and they solved quite a bit of it but
uh very few people solved the whole
puzzle because as I mentioned there are
loads and twists and turns okay so it
looks like a straight up Pawn race it's
white to move white pushes the d-pawn
and there you go one step forward black
does the same of course and now here was
the pitfall the pitfall was you must not
promote to a queen because you should
promote the the pawn will actually
promote as well to a queen and then this
is the crunch point that once the queen
comes to give check and you think hey
this is going to be an easy win the king
is going to protect the queen but the
answer is no the king can actually
capture the pawn on B3 and after Queen
takes Queen it is the dreaded stale mate
so this was a big twist number one so
you could not promote to a queen so
let's go back to this position and so in
this one loads of people got this one
right it was a very neat idea that you
promote to a bishop
and then the whole point is that after
the pawn does promote to a queen you can
give that check in safety and the King
takes Pawn isn't that scary because this
bishop takes Queen no cell mate for you
today and uh but then there was another
twist so let's go back and this is where
I feel like this is like part one and
then there's part two because after D7
it wasn't actually compulsory for black
to go running with the a pawn he could
actually trap and play King takes pawn
and uh if you were to promote to a queen
that would also be a big because after
porn moves to A2 and the queen comes out
to just defend against their promotion
of that phone black would promote
anywhere anyway and after Queen takes
Queen stalemate once more
so
here it is
and this is so so cool in this
particular position white promotes to a
rook so we've had like the bishop under
promotion now we've got the Rook under
promotion and now the coolest line here
is if the black king steps forward to A2
this is so nice and then the race begins
so David is going to put those boots and
then the Rook Gets behind the pawn and
here it comes Pawn promotes Rook takes
queen king takes work
white actually runs with the pawn
nothing for it and here comes the final
promotion promotion to a queen
I know we've had the bishop we've had
the rook and now we've got the queen and
then the whole point once black promotes
to a queen oh dear Queen comes to C2 and
it is Checkmate and this is the kind of
puzzle that gives you a Big Thrill when
you solve it you get this kind of ah
Eureka moment you share it with your
friends and it's just a fantastic study
by Vitaly kovalenko fantastic wow what a
puzzle that was difficult twists and
turns